وعايزين
اولا هناك الاثر على الشعب الاخرى
من بلادهم من النساء والاطفال فقط
دعاياتي الحرب العالميه الثانيه وقامت
بالهجوم على دوله معترف بها في منظمه
الامم المتحده كذلك الحب تاثرت على
امدادات المواد الغذائيه بصوره اساسيه
واسعار المواد الغذائيه تم
تمركه في المنقبه لكافه
اوروبا
الاخير
بالنسبه
اساسيه فقط
نقطه مفصليه حول اذا ما كانت القواعد
الدوليه سوف يتم احترام وهو الالتزام بها
عام تم تتم مخالفه لها وهنا كانت تهديدات
لاستخدام حتى السلاح النووي من كما تمت
مناقشتهم من قبل الجانب الروسي لذا هذه
اللحظه المفصليه مليئه بالتحديات للنظام
العالمي وتاتي في مرحله عندما تقوم عندما
نجد ان هناك ازمات عالميه كثيره
هي مجرد الفاتحه